l'exode des habitants de cramât tort sq
car ferroviaire élégante mais alerte
aérienne permanente
la ville est en train de se vider de ses
habitants la russie a fait de cette
région du dombass son nouvel objectif
militaire visage fermé avant ce départ
pour l'ouest du pays
ici c'est trop dangereux il faut partir
quelques temps et revenir éventuellement
plus tard peut-être
sur les quais des vieillards des
infirmes et cette femme bouleversée elle
reste pour s'occuper de sa mère mais
laisse partir sa fille
le gouverneur de la région a instamment
demandé à tous ces civils d'évacuer la
ville au plus vite
il va y avoir une grande bataille ici
donc tout le monde vit dans la peur et
c'est normal
énormes files d'attentes devant les
stations-service pour ceux qui fuient
par la route
cette nuit en plein centre ville cette
école a été frappé par un missile russe
moscou vise est peut-être le
commissariat central situé juste à côté
un avant goût de ce que pourrait être
l'enfer de cramât d'or sq les habitants
qui ne sont pas encore parties savent
qu'ils sont désormais en grand danger
je crois que les russes ne céderons
jamais sur le thon basse ils ont laissé
tomber kiev qui met ici ils
n'abandonneront jamais
nous nous rendons sur une partie de
cette ligne de front est où tout va
désormais se jouer
ces soldats se craignent un se préparer
à cette nouvelle offensive russe
tension palpable en ce moment l'ennemi
fait voler des drones au dessus de nous
faites attention
ces tranchées viennent tout juste d'être
creusé des soldats plus combatif que
jamais les exactions des russes autour
de kiev sont dans tous les esprits
ce sont des violences inhumaines contre
les civils
ces russes sont je pense bien plus que
des fascistes
des massacres qui explique ton parti 7,8
des civils
plus d'un mois après le début de la
guerre ce nouvel exode donne le
sentiment que l'histoire se répète cette
fois c'est cette ville de craon motors
qui redoute une offensive russe majeur